hello everybody and welcome back to
another video now in today's episode
we're going to be checking out the first
official insider build
of windows 11 that was just recently
released by microsoft
this is billed 22 000.50
and if you're a member of the windows
insider program you can get it
right now by going into your windows
update settings in the settings
application
and checking for updates and there
should be a new update for this build
now
i would highly recommend and microsoft
certainly recommends that if you do want
to check this out do so on a secondary
device or in a virtual machine
because this is a development build
there are bugs we will be getting into
some of those later on in this video
it's not intended to be a daily use
operating system yet
so just to show you if we open up wenver
here this is again
build 22 0.51
though it does identify the version
number as 21 h2 which is a windows 10
version number 21 h2 is currently in the
insider phase it hasn't been officially
released yet but this is an update to
windows 10.
so this insider build of windows 11 here
is just using that version number even
though this is a completely different
version of the operating system
technically but
there are a lot of similarities and you
can see right off the bat if you saw my
original video or if you saw any
screenshots of the leaked build i'm sure
this looks
extremely familiar to what you saw and
there's a good reason for that because
the leaked builds build number
was 21 996.1 and again this build is 22
000.51 so those build numbers are very
close but that doesn't mean there are
no changes in this operating system or
in this build of the operating system
here there absolutely are and we're
going to jump into them right now
so one of the first things is the new
file explorer design
now the design of the contents of the
window have remained unchanged we have
the same icon
same address bar same search bar uh all
of this up here at least this this row
here was in windows 10 right and windows
8 before that
what has changed is what we have on the
menu bar up here because the ribbon
interface has been completely
removed it is no longer here it has been
simplified
with this single row of icons so let's
go to the desktop here and
let's check these items out from left to
right
so the first option is new which allows
you to make a new folder or a new item
now there is a redundancy here because
within new item we have folder again so
both of these items do the same thing
you've got new shortcut bitmap image
text document compress
zip folder in fact these are the same
options that you would get
in the right-click context menu when you
right-click and go to new
and you get all those items there you
have that same exact list of items here
and we will get into the context menu in
a moment because it has
been redesigned as well from what we saw
in the last build
now right here you've got cut copy paste
this is rename if i actually hover over
say this microsoft edge shortcut here
you can see i can rename it
i can share it move it to the trash or
recycle it since we're on windows here
my sorting options are over here so this
allows me to sort items by name date
modified type etc
next to that you have your layout and
view options which allows you to change
the view of the folder you can view
large icons medium icons details etc
and one of the other neat things is this
compact view button here
which as you see it says decrease space
between items now one of the things i
mentioned in the last video on this
the spacing in between the folders is
pretty significant this is not how it
was on windows 10 windows 10 there was
like essentially no space
in between these items here now you can
see there is a
prominent pronounced space in between
our folders here so what this compact
view does is it gets rid of that and it
makes it more windows 10 like so now you
can see they're
closer together and it makes the quick
access and everything over here closer
together and this is exactly how windows
10's file
explorer currently behaves so here is a
window for my host computer for
comparison
you can see how things look and yeah
this is a very welcome feature by me
personally because i'm not a huge fan of
this
non-compact view now let's talk about
the context menu which as you can see
has been changed here uh pretty
substantially now in
the last build the leaked build of
windows 11
the context menu was updated but the
contents of it essentially remained
unchanged it was just the design of it
you know it got rounded corners and it
fit in better with the design language
that microsoft is going for with windows
11 here but now
just like in final explorer there is
more spacing in between these items here
now it just so happens that the context
menu displayed properly when i happen to
right click it here but there is a bug
with the context menu that it normally
does not display properly so you can see
when i'm right clicking here notice how
for
like a split second you can see the edge
of the context menu and then it just
gets cut off
and okay so here it is working now so
this is how it's supposed to look but
most of the time
it does not display properly and it
displays with this cut off edge here to
where
when i try to go to new items here you
can see there's this massive
gap in between these two menus here the
sub menus also have this new animation
where they fly down from the top which
is pretty nice but this context menu
is not complete you can see there's a
show more options but
here when you click on this it brings up
the older style context menu which
i much prefer compared to this much
larger one
and uh this is the same when you right
click on icons so if i
right click on firefox for instance uh
you can see it now displays properly
here it seems to display properly when
you right click on an item
uh though you can see here the one for
recycle bin has not been updated yet but
everything else including when i right
click on this folder here does have this
newer design
now one of the interesting changes
they've made is they've added this new
bar
down here at the very bottom and this is
also present uh
uh what oh i think it's oh explorer just
crashed there okay
uh yeah now this the position of this
moves like if i click on or right click
on microsoft edge here see it's at the
very top this is supposed to be
closest to your cursor but this is a ui
element from microsoft office where when
you right click you get these kind of
quick
options to cut copy paste but yeah you
still also
get the the show more options down here
and you can see how large this menu is
as it is imagine them bringing all these
options
over to this style context menu that's
not really going to work
especially with the resolution i've got
this vm set to right now like it would
go from top to bottom i'm certain that
this
show more options menu is a placeholder
because
you know this is not really user
friendly having two separate menus here
like to get to
an option i have to click on this it
opens up a new menu so this is this is
certainly a
placeholder at least i would hope it is
now let's move on to the action center
as it has been substantially updated
compared to what we've seen
previously and the first major change is
there's no longer an
action center button in the system tray
normally there is a dedicated button
in between the clock and the show
desktop button which is still here by
the way though it is
really really tiny it's not even a
pronounced button anymore
but it does still work as you can see
but yeah there's no action center button
anymore this is because the action
center has been
split up so it's no longer one ui
element anymore it's actually
two now so to get to your notifications
you now click on
the clock down here which now not only
opens up the calendar but also your
notifications up here
so you can still make the calendar
larger by clicking this button here and
yes this takes effect even when you
close out of it and go back into it and
obviously the design
of the calendar has been changed along
with the notifications area up here
so if i make this smaller the
notification center becomes larger and
yeah here's all your notifications
i can click on clear all to get rid of
them and that moves the entire
notification center away so now nothing
will show up so it doesn't show up
unless you have
a new notification now to get to your
actual actions
like focus assist and all of that you
now have to click on
your network and volume buttons down
here which are no longer two separate
buttons you can see it's one combined
button here so you click on this
and it gives you access to your volume
slider
your controls from action center how it
was in windows 10 so you've got night
light focus assist accessibility options
etc
and presumably this would also show you
wi-fi networks to connect to if you were
using
wi-fi to connect to the internet which
in this case i'm not since this is a
virtual machine
now you can modify this by clicking on
the pencil button down here to add
keyboard layout and project which are
your two other options here
and last but not least we have a
shortcut down here to open up the newly
redesigned settings application which we
will
touch on in a moment but that is the
current state of the action center
and it'll be interesting to see how
microsoft changes it
throughout the rest of windows 11's
development process
next thing i want to touch on is the
taskbar you may have noticed that it has
changed a little bit
compared to the leaked build
specifically the size of it so in the
leaked build
the size of the taskbar compared to
windows 10
increased by a hair to where there was a
third row over here in the clock for the
day of the week
another pretty significant change that i
didn't touch on in the last video is
microsoft's apparent removal of the use
small taskbar icons option in the
settings application now when windows 7
was introduced and the super bar which
is the larger taskbar
size was introduced microsoft had the
option to where you could shrink that
down to make it look more like the
traditional taskbar that people were
used to
at that time from windows vista and
prior and that is a feature that is
still in windows 10 but in windows 11 it
isn't so if i were to right click on the
taskbar and go to taskbar settings and i
scroll down here
to taskbar behaviors where i can change
the alignment of the taskbar to the left
i can automatically hide it show badges
but there's nothing about
use small taskbar icons now the good
news is
if you want to change the size of your
taskbar you can
by adding a d word value to the windows
registry
you can actually choose between three
different sizes small
medium or large but like i said the
option is
nowhere to be found in the settings app
so it's possible that it could have just
been removed temporarily while it was
being redesigned
or perhaps microsoft is going to be
removing
that feature from windows 11 but let's
hope that that isn't the case
something else of note that i found out
well and this is by the way this is the
new settings app we will touch on this i
mean
we have it opened here so we will go
through it but i have not
activated this build i have not put in
my windows 10 pro product key which by
the way yes you can use to activate
windows 11 builds but
i can still customize these settings
here so you see right up here it says
you need to activate windows before you
can personalize your pc
now in the leaked build i was not able
to move the taskbar over to the left
side without activating the build
with a windows 10 pro product key but i
can do that here
with no problem now this is interesting
and my guess is this is a bug
because if you go back up a page to this
the regular personalization settings
here
and i go to background you can see none
of this can be changed
i cannot change the the desktop
wallpaper i mean you can
by just downloading an image and
right-clicking and setting as desktop
background you'll be able to do that for
years it is a bit of a work around by
the way
but i can't change the theme if i try to
go
here i can't change any of this i cannot
change
the colors i can't enable dark mode but
i can
go to taskbar and change the alignment
of the taskbar so maybe they're going to
intentionally allow you to change the
task personalization settings without it
being activated but
i would assume if it says you need to
activate ones before you can personalize
your pc that would apply to all
personalization settings as it has
in windows 10 i mean in windows 10
without it being activated you cannot
for example enable small taskbar icons
you have to have the build activated or
your operating system activated to do
that
so it'll be interesting to see if this
gets changed but my guess now is this is
just a bug but yes by the way
this is the new settings application it
has been substantially redesigned
you've got new icons all across the
board a new
menu design here so you kind of have
this looks similar to what we saw in the
new action center and just the design of
uh
these these buttons here this this
really fits in uh with that design
and uh yeah it looks very very nice i
honestly really like it i like these new
icons i think it looks great it'll be
neat to see
where it goes but yeah there you have it
now let's talk about some things that
have not
changed and one of those is the start
menu it has
not been changed compared to what we saw
in the last build you have
the exact same design you have the same
pre-installed applications which is
still kind of unfortunate the design of
the all apps menu this is exactly what
we saw
in the leaked build nothing of notes
here the getting started application or
the get started let's see if this has
changed
i've actually not tested this off camera
yes it has the images have been changed
so previously in the leaked build there
were images of a windows 10
installation here search has also
remained unchanged compared to what we
saw in the leaked build
in terms of design at least so i'm not
really going to go into that
but there it is something that has
changed is the
widgets panel which previously you would
open this up you'd have to sign in with
your microsoft account but you had these
widgets here you could not
move them around you could not add more
widgets now you can i can move these
around i can rearrange them however i
want
uh they no longer when you try to drag
them off to your desktop they no longer
create
a shortcut to a page on msn.com like i
did before
so that has been fixed and you can add
new widgets now so i can go here and i
can add
the esports widget tips calendar traffic
to do
this is all tied to your microsoft
account you have to be signed in to use
it
last but not least let's talk about the
microsoft store as it has gotten a
visual overhaul so this is the new
design of it here now unfortunately
the ability to run android apps on
windows 11 which was a major feature
announced at the june 24th keynote
that has not been implemented yet and
once that feature gets
implemented i assume it will in one of
these insider builds
uh i will be doing a video on that at
least i want to but we'll see what
happens when
when that time eventually comes around
now as i said earlier there
are a few bugs well more than a few bugs
with this build of windows 11 and i will
have
this neowin article down below if you'd
like to read up on them so yeah just
another huge disclaimer here if you're
planning on installing this build just
don't do it on your main computer
because
there are more than a few bugs in the
operating system and i mean this is a
development build you should not
install it on a machine that you use
daily for doing your work or playing
games or whatever right but
using it in a vm or on a secondary
machine that's that's really what this
was designed for here to test it out
that's what the insider program is all
about but yeah
there you have it guys that is a first
look at windows 11 build 22
000.51 the first publicly available
insider build released by microsoft guys
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up be sure to get
subscribed and turn on
notifications if you haven't already to
get notified whenever i upload a new
video which i do multiple times every
single week on this channel
and as always guys i want to thank you
all so much for watching and i'll see
you
in the next video
[Music]
so
[Music]
you